[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning john it's been a very good
a pretty hard week brandon lee milligan
was on our podcast i was on one of my
favorite tech podcasts decoder i
recorded a thing that i'm very excited
about but won't come out until next
month study hall launched its first four
series communications american history
college math and rhetoric and
composition and it was esther day but
also i had some trouble sleeping because
i was stressed out about some stuff
there are a lot of people waiting on me
for things and some days i feel like i
can meet all my obligations other days i
don't feel like i can meet any so today
to simplify my life and for the vibes i
just wanted to share this video of some
people from complexly and dftba and
other friends helping make the project
for awesome hankler fish art which you
can only get during the project for
awesome thanks to everybody who ordered
this year it was hot and windy and we
were sweaty and achy but the work got
done and it felt real good john i'll see
you on tuesday